au cours de mon existence j'ai eu
l'occasion d'expérimenter de nombreux
rythmes de vie sains et un rythme mille
à l'heure où l'instinct les décisions
rapides de dominer et ô mon coeur
battait la chamade et puis un rythme où
j'ai dû réduire et maîtriser ma
fréquence cardiaque pour atteindre mes
objectifs
mes objectifs sportifs
de la prise en charge d'un choeur
d'enfants à ma préparation pour faire
l'escaras d' une très haute montagne je
vais donc vous faire part de ses deux
passions qui modulent et le rythme de ma
vie
je suis une landaise
modeste part très brillante
mais qui est déterminé et pragmatique
dans tout ce qu'elle entreprend
une scolarité tout ce qu'il ya de plus
banal mais surtout marquée par
du sport du vélo dans la course à pied
or notre sprint l'été et l'hiver du
handball
mon père et mon frère était dans l'armée
de l'air mon frère avait 17 ans de plus
que moi et prestige de l'uniforme oblige
j'avais décidé que je serais sûrs de
chasse
deux écueils le premier je suis une
femme est dans l'armée de l'air à
l'époque alors qu'aux états unis il y
avait des femmes en france il n'y en
avait pas et le deuxième c'est comme mon
niveau en mathématiques était quand même
plutôt au ras des pâquerettes
cependant j'ai quand même eu la chance
de pouvoir voulait sur un avion de
chasse de l'armée de l'air un alphajet à
cazaux dans les landes une expérience
incroyable et qui m'a permis surtout de
ne pas regretter ne pas être pilote de
chasse en effet c'est un métier
excessivement physique vous ressortez
lessivé de l'avion et on comprend qu'à
40 ans tous ces pilotes sont obligés de
décrocher donc mon bac en poche il
allait bien falloir que je me décide à
trouver un job pour gagner ma vie
comme toujours
je vais au cinéma et cet été là je suis
allé voir un film américain tiré d'un
livre qui s'appelait femme de médecin de
franck son auteur un des protagonistes
avaient reçu une balle dans le coeur
comme toujours les américains film sur
le vif en direct la caméra survole bloc
opératoire on voit le coeur qui bat la
machine qui le remplaçait le coeur et le
coeur qui s'arrête le chirurgien qui
fait une incision qui rentrent le doigt
dans le coeur et qui sort la balle mais
c'est bien sûr c'est ça que je vais
faire chirurgien cardiaque
alors bien sûr six années d'études après
un premier concours de preuves de
d'entrée
mais c'est pas avec ça que vous allez
être chirurgien il faut passer
l'internât l'internât un sacré concours
40 élus pour 800 prétendants pour ceux
qui ont l'occasion de passer des
concours ou qu'on prendrait
effectivement conte et ses battements
cardiaques le jour du concours quand on
vous donne les sujets à traiter
donc
je suis parti une fois le bac en poche
l'internât en poche pardon
dans le service du professeur francis
fons temps francis fons temps est un
chirurgien cardiaque pédiatrique
mondialement connue puisque une
intervention porte son nom
et le jour du choix le président de
l'internât de l'époque a dit regardez la
bien parce que dans six mois vous la
verrez plus je laisse à chacun
interprété la douceur de cette phrase
les relations avec le professeur france
en ont été un peu un peu difficile parce
que je pense que c'était deux caractères
qui s'affrontent déjà externe dans son
service j'avais écrit une lettre
comprend n'avait rien appris chez lui
donc au bout de six mois un petit peu
houleux quand même je me suis dit que je
ne ferai plus jamais chirurgie cardiaque
et ben c'était pas le cas parce que il y
avait je ne dis pas de l'autre côté de
la rue mais de l'autre côté du couloir
du bloc opératoire que notre service de
chirurgie cardiaque ou finalement j'ai
été accueilli à bras ouverts et où j'ai
fait toute ma
ma mon expérience et j'ai appris mon
métier
je compare souvent un géorgien cardiaque
un pilote d'ailleurs en aval quand vous
vous posez sur un porte-avion vous
pouvez vous poser n'importe où dans le
monde quand vous savez faire la
chirurgie cardiaque pédiatrique où
pouvaient opérer tous les choeurs
d'adultes par contre l' inverse est
beaucoup plus périlleux 1 j'ai été nommé
après notre concours
praticiens hospitaliers et j'ai aidé mon
chef de service jusqu'en 1993 et ce
jusqu'en 2015 ou à ce moment là j'ai
assumé pleinement la responsabilité de
cette chirurgie que vous dire de plus
sur cette facette que la chirurgie
cardiaque pédiatrique est une chirurgie
extrêmement exigeante difficile prenante
avec
des histoires belle mais des histoires
aussi dramatique il faut savoir que
nous avons la vie et la mort entre les
mains lorsque les battements du coeur
s'arrête la vie s'arrête le coeur c'est
le moteur et nous avons ce pouvoir
d'arrêter les choeurs de les réparer et
de les faire partir
trois petites histoires pour étayer
cette cette vie de chirurgien
il a 6 ans c'est un blondinet hyper
sympathique on lui fait une correction
chirurgicale sur la voie pulmonaire
c'est-à-dire l'artère qui va du
ventricule droit au poumon pour oxygéner
le coeur la réparation se passe bien on
est tous très contents et le lendemain
matin on arrive coup de bambou en fait
le gamin était ce qu'on appelle en me
briat bilatérales en coma dépassé c'est
à dire que le cerveau ne fonctionnait
plus du tout alors que le coeur battait
toujours les parents étaient absolument
admirable puisqu'ils ont donné
l'autorisation qu'il y ait le
prélèvement des organes de rein et de
foi
et nous on était confronté à un problème
et on n'aime pas les problèmes sans
solution parce que ces problèmes peuvent
se répéter nous avons donc rejoint
l'équipe de transplantation cardiaque de
transplantation de prélèvement d'organes
et nous sommes allés examiner le coeur
et effectivement on a compris le
problème il y avait une communication
entre les oreillettes entre l'oreille à
droite et l'oreillette gauche quand on
répare un coeur au louvre il ya de l'air
qui rentre à l'intérieur une fois
refermé on s'assure d'avoir la meilleure
purge qui nient plus d'air
malheureusement deux ou trois d'entre
elles bulles d'air se sont rappelés au
niveau des ventricules son parti à
travers les orcs et l'autre la
communication et son parti au cerveau
ayant détruit le cerveau une deuxième
deuxième exemple qui on est tu être tout
aussi dramatique mais qui finalement a
fini façon sympathique c'est une dame
courait au père pour la troisième fois
les chirurgies est compliquée et donc on
va assister le coeur avec cette fameuse
machine circulation extracorporelle et
que pour que le sang circule dans ses
tuyaux sango annulé on utilise de
l'héparine et lorsque l'héparine n'a
plus à jouer son rôle on utilise un
autre produit pour neutraliser et
récupérer une coagulation normale qu'on
appelle la protéine jeudi ou chefs de
clinique on verra tout à l'heure avec la
protamines si on aura ajouté des points
pour ne pas que ça cei et la lanterne
anesthésie entend protamines et 101 dire
sans à personne injecte le produit dans
les 20 secondes qui ont suivi l'oxygène
à terre c'est bouché plein de caillots
et la circulation s'est arrêtée le
progrès social tombe sur toute l'équipe
qu'à cela ne tienne dans la pièce à côté
il ya une machine qui tourne 24 heures
sur 24 pour lorsqu un arrêt cardiaque
qu'on puisse éventuellement l'utiliser
nous avons donc pu changer en moins de
trois minutes
les deux machines et nous avons récupéré
une circulation et nous avons récupéré
des battements cardiaques et finalement
le malade aujourd'hui va bien
le troisième petit exemple je dis petit
vous allez pourquoi
et quand même très sympathique
elle est au cinquième mois de grossesse
hélas les échos foetale de contrôle
découvre une masse intracardiaque au
niveau cardiaque
il arrive gynécologues et obstétriciens
a amené cette patiente jusqu'au septième
mois elle arrive aux blocs opératoires
dans une dans une des salles ont fait la
césarienne enfin les spécialistes pour
la césarienne
un petit bébé d'1 kg 7 sort et on la
mène directement dans la salle
opératoire d'à côté il est technique et
les préparer et là j'ouvre le sternum
pour traiter cette humeur
l'horreur mais c'est tout petit c'est la
taille d'un abricot 1 kg et d'un kilo 7
et lahore télé comme mon petit doigt
mais comment mettre toutes nos
machinerie heureusement la nature cette
fois ci a été sympathique la tumeur
était extra carnac il a suffi d'un coup
de ciseaux il a suffi d'un petit peu
d'hémostase aujourd'hui c'est un gamin
d'une dizaine d'années qui est en pleine
forme
c'est dans ces moments là que l'on doit
retrouver les qualités d'un chirurgien
cardiaque c'est à dire la rapidité de
décision
la rapidité d'action le geste précis
mais avant toute chose un calme olympien
olympiques ou olympien comme vous voulez
c'est à dire que si le capitaine du
bateau s'affole toute l'équipe s'affole
et donc là il faut rester d'une zénitude
absolue c'est comme ça que l'on arrive
effectivement à faire du bon boulot je
dis toujours contre en chacun de nous il
existe un dîner et un acquis l'acquis ce
sont ces années et ces années que l'on
passe à côté de nous de nos aînés et qui
nous transmettent leurs expériences et
line et c'est ce que l'on a en chacun de
nous cet instinct ce sixième sens ce
feeling qui nous fait prendre la bonne
décision au bon moment ces deux vertus
ces deux valeurs j'ai toujours essayé
pendant l'exercice de le transmettre aux
plus jeunes ce qu'on appelle le
compagnonnage on n'apprend pas dans les
livres on n'apprend pas dans les congrès
on apprend sur le tas et vous êtes
heureux le jour où l'élève dépasse le
maître c'est ainsi qu'on va faire
progresser notre discipline en 2003 je
vais basculer dans un monde complètement
à l'opposé de la chirurgie cardiaque
qu'on appelle la très haute montagne on
pourrait raconter un petit peu cette
histoire selon les trois tomes de frison
roche frison roche qui a écrit en 1942
premier de cordée premier tome le
deuxième tome la grande crevasse le
troisième tome retour à la montagne
premier de cordée
ce matin-là entraîné un catalogue de
allibert trekking dont la couverture
représentait le massif du mont blanc
comme j'étais un petit peu las de toutes
mes activités sportives je me suis dit
mais qu'à cela ne tienne je vais
peut-être en faire l'escaladent et c'est
parti comme ça le premier sommet de 1800
mètres à peu près c'est le pic du midi
d'ossau celtique emblématique de la
vallée du même nom dans les pyrénées
atlantiques le pic que j'ai fait avec un
guide qui s'appelle frais de choses et
avec qui depuis j'ai dû faire moins une
cinquantaine de sommer l'accordé le
guide et son client sa cliente par la
suite tu fais le mont blanc parce que
5000 m et puis j'ai fait le kilimandjaro
pour moi un anniversaire presque 6000 m
et puis je suis parti là-bas au fin fond
de la cordillère des andes pour faire la
conca mois presque 7000 mètres est alors
bien sûr il faut faire un 8000 mais qu'à
cela ne tienne je ferais l'everest mais
pourquoi l'everest direz vous eh bien là
aussi encore des lectures
maurice herzog maurice herzog a fait
partie de cette équipe qui a froid faim
qui a vaincu le premier 8000 annapurna
premier 8000 et je n'avais comprenait
pas qu'on puisse monter à eau et revenir
avec des doigts gelés qu'on est obligé
d'amputer autant les mains que les pieds
il son deuxième livre ça s'appelle les
grandes aventures himalayenne est il
rapporté son expérience au niveau de
l'everest et l'everest des photos
c'était des colonnes de sherpa habillé
de trois fois rien parfois même pieds
nus qui portait des normes caisse pour
que toute l'expédition puisse aller au
sommet de la montagne et je me suis dit
mais c'est là bas que je vais aller voir
ce qui se passe et c'est ainsi qu'en
2007 je suis arrivée
8650 qui est le sommet du sud qui est
décoté népalais et c'est grâce à bath
eng le sherpa qui m'a quand même
beaucoup aidé pour arriver là où les
sherpas sont un peuple extraordinaire de
générosité de gentillesse pourtant la
manière rien il ne marche qu'avec les
pieds ne marche pas avec les vélos les
voitures etc on est vraiment dans la
vraie vie
et donc
en 2010 va s'écrire le deuxième volume
la grande crevasse
c'est failli être celle dans laquelle
j'aurais pu tomber
cette année là nous partons à la face
nord côté tibétain
nous sommes neuf alpinistes aucun on ira
au sommet un d'entre eux a fait un 2ème
cérébrale sévère il a failli y rester et
moi j'ai fait une phlébite bilatérales
embolie pulmonaire une thrombose de la
veine centrale de la rétine
je suis descendu de la montagne à dos de
sherpa je suis arrivé au camp de base la
poitrine en sang
si la sagesse a été présente à la
première ascension elle n'a pas été à la
deuxième d'ailleurs la première
ascension à 8 650 vous auriez pu me dire
mais pourquoi ne pas avoir fait les 200
derniers mètres il faut savoir que la
montagne elle est très exigeante à ce
niveau si vous n'arrivez pas à une heure
précise à une zone précise tout retard
accumulé vous allez le payer là où il
n'y en a quelques-uns qui ont persisté à
monthey qui ne sont plus là pour en
parler
alors pour la deuxième expédition que
s'est il passé eh bien là nous n'avons
pas respecté les paliers c'est un peu
comme en plongée sous marine vous devez
monter 400 m tous les jours pas plus or
nous avons fait 1000 mètres en deux
jours et donc le mal des montagnes mal
aigu des montagnes est arrivé maux de
tête céphalées vomissements
bref bien ce moment là on a dit plus
jamais ça
mais voilà dix ans après c'est à dire
aujourd'hui on va écrire le troisième
tome retour à la montagne
en début d'année marc batard qui est ce
qu on appelle ce qu'on a appelé le
précise sprinteur de l'everest c'est un
garçon ans un guide de haute montagne
qui a gravi l'everest camp de base
sommet aller-retour en 22 heures sans
oxygène mon cher arrivé à 8 650 mètres
en quatre jours
donc
on se rappelle au mois de mai et je lui
demande des nouvelles et il me dit mais
est ce que ça te dit de venir et que
croyez vous que j'ai répondu
mais bien sûr et donc me voilà repartie
actuellement dans cette grande aventure
c'est une expédition
qui ne sera pas commercial mais qui
risque d'être très médiatisée c'est une
expédition tout à fait différente comme
on dit j'ai changé les gangs pour les
crampons
l'idée c'est une préparation physique
une préparation alimentaire et surtout
une préparation mentale il faut
absolument maîtriser ce mental qui vous
pompe une énergie folle on peut utiliser
l'auto hypnose la méditation
la respiration en cohérence cardiaque
bref c'est très important de canaliser
son énergie pour arriver en haut et
je me suis dit que pour une fois ce ne
sera pas mon ascension mais ce sera
l'ascension du coeur du coeur des hommes
et surtout du coeur de mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque
j'irai et planter le drapeau de mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque tout là-haut mécénat
a été créée en
1983 par francine leca ici présentes
dans ces deux cas première femme
chirurgien cardiaque dont l'idée était
de opérer des enfants atteints de
pathologies cardiaques dans des pays
complètement démuni de structures
sanitaires dignes de ce nom et donc
pendant des années elle s'est occupée de
ses enfants et elle aussi la retraite
étant arrivée elle a dispatché ces
petits gamins sur l'ensemble du
territoire français dans 9 centres dont
celui de bordeaux est donc j'ai pu
participer à cette grande oeuvre
humanitaire
est donc aujourd'hui vous remercier
francine pour qui j'ai beaucoup de
respect et beaucoup d'affection j'irai
porté très haut
les couleurs de mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque
la route va être longue difficile mais
la destination est merveilleuse vous
l'avez donc compris
entre la chirurgie cardiaque et la
montagne
deux mondes qui s'opposent la chirurgie
cardiaque il n'y a pas de place pour
l'improvisation tout est cadré bien bien
défini
même les risques sont calculés on essaye
de tout maîtriser j'ai donc été dans
cette hyper maîtrise du geste toujours à
cent à l'heure
mais
actuellement je suis dans tout dans
l'opposé le contraire la montagne la
montagne c'est l'éloge de la lenteur
c'est l'éloge du lâcher prise c'est
l'éloge de l'adaptabilité c'est l'éloge
de la patience et le risque ou les
connaissez mais vous pouvez pas les
prévoir pour une fois l'homme propose
mais c'est la nature qui dispose et que
ce soit la montagne comme la chirurgie
cardiaque ce sont quand même deux choses
qui accélère en permanence les
battements de notre coeur est donc tout
là haut au sommet quel que soit le
sommet le corps va enfin se taire et le
coeur va parler à son âme namasté
[Applaudissements]